dealing anymore I think it's because you
have a very proactive approach to life
yeah
right so like some people they go you
know despite the odds I'm gonna change
my environment I'm gonna just even
though I feel like [ __ ] right now I
don't want to be in [ __ ] anymore
yeah but then there's also another group
of people where they don't feel like
they can control their destiny yeah so I
think the people that are in that world
their reality is more like hey man like
don't tell me I can control this I tried
I can't yeah but so there's difference
even in psychology there's different
schools of thought right there's the
holistic side where more like you don't
use pills but you use your own like
reinforcements so meaning like be able
therapy yeah like but even within
cognitive behavioral therapy some
believe that you should do it along with
pharmaceuticals yeah like because you
need you need the balance of taking your
pills and then you have your treatment
and then you you can go that way but
there's also another cap that's like not
you don't need any pills all you got to
do is hit it straight forward and try to
like you know change your your situation
it seems like people's ability to like
cope with certain situations is the big
you know issue right it's like some
people have a better ability to cope
with a stressful situation like you
would experience and then some people
would be in that same position and be
like [ __ ] no I'm never doing this again
yeah because that is so crippling to
them but they're like I can't do it but
your ability to cope with a certain
situation is a lot easier for them we're
not easier but there's able to say okay
they're able to analyze what's happening
and then move forward with that yeah and
it seems like sometimes I get clients
that are like that to where their
relationship with like exercise or
eating clean or whatever is they're just
like they look at it from a frame of
dude I don't want to [ __ ] do this
sounds like the worst thing ever
mhm and then they don't want to deal
with their ability to like eat healthy
or whatever that means to them I just I
think to that point you like I really
want people to understand I guess if
there was a takeaway yeah is that when
some
he says from their perspective where
they say hey like I go what you go go
through as well I can empathize but I'm
trying to get you to change your mind
your your your your position on it yeah
that's it nothing positive I don't want
you to think that that person's being
dismissive of how you feel right but you
have a choice it's difficult because so
here's a thing a lot of people have
different perspectives obvious yeah so
like the the biggest the biggest problem
here is we all live in different
realities like reality the reality is
what we believe in it's highly
subjective yeah so I call this system
called bad right it's it's ba-dee right
and and so like B stands for believe a
is like awareness like self-awareness
and then D is like direction or
discipline right so you use this in
order to frame and change a person's
mind it all starts with belief like if
you don't believe that something can be
done then you can't even have a
conversation with them so if they some
people believe that hey I I'm diagnosed
with depression I'm gonna live with this
all my life this is this is I'm never
gonna it's always gonna be a part of who
I am right there's other people that
believe hey I am diagnosed with
depression but now I'm gonna figure out
how to change my situation and this
applies to anything like hey I'm poor
I'm gonna be like this all my life and
there's other people like I'm poor now
but I will not be because I'm gonna do
everything I can to get out of this yeah
so you got a first attack their belief
not attacking the way where you debate
them I think a lot of it is like this is
your world right and when you want to
show people your world the more they
feel attacked the more they close up
yeah because what's happening is a lot
of people want to be comfortable and
they don't know that they're addicted to
their repetitive like reality people get
married to their circumstance a lot
right cuz it feels much better to to
have somebody go oh are you okay
I'm like that too I'm dead everyone is
yeah but we don't know we're we don't we
don't know that it's happened to man you
get defensive when somebody tells you
that's what you're doing you want to
tell them you don't [ __ ] know me
because it's like telling someone this
it's like hey man I feel sick I'm sick
and then they're like no you're not
that's what they hear that's what they
hear is that you you just you just gotta
sleep you'll be better and you're just
like man I just want to vent right
sometimes I think you gotta listen to
what they're trying to say and then once
you you got it helped them frame their
world so then you you changed your
belief system and then you got to change
the way that they are aware of them
there's their own like actions right cuz
if you don't have self-awareness
you can't look into yourself and start
changing what needs to be done or even
know that you have the power to change
your world and your reality and your
whole entire thing you you feel
defenseless especially if you're
depressed and you're just like like at
the bottom I think a lot of us do tend
to speak from a very combative point of
view right yeah so it's it's it's so
tense yeah yeah intense and it's very
hard to get up like so I I had to learn
this specifically with Mariel yeah only
because how I grew up in my house things
were said very straightforward and it is
what it is
right so I just I don't get any feelings
attached to things right so a Mariel had
a big issue with hearing the word no
from me I guess no was not read much
around because it she took it as a
personal attack yes right it's not like
you were denying her her intelligence or
anything but she fills in the blanks and
creates the story yeah I think that's
where the self-awareness comes from yeah
if she doesn't understand that she's
doing that she thinks you're the problem
yeah you're fighting her you're mean to
her you're the problem because you're
hurting my feelings and it's coming from
her point of view as I'm very demeaning
towards her it's like yeah and there's a
you know that we mentioned this before
where everybody has a certain a lot of
skeletons in their closet that they
don't even realize it's there yeah so
when if they like for her what she found
out is that because I guess like how she
grew up and you know being in a Korean
household sometimes when Korean parents
talk to you they talk to you as if
you're the dumbest person we are and
they talk to us like we're [ __ ] dumb
and so sometimes like I guess when it
comes from somebody close to her and she
heard here's somebody go against what
she
well she doesn't here's the word no she
heard she hears you're stupid yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna speak for you because
you don't know what you're talking about
yeah and for me just objectively I'm
just saying oh no I disagree with what
you're saying yeah and but think that's
how it was in my household right so I
learned now to just be a little more
crafty with my words and not outright
say no right because I have to
understand you know people's reality
exactly you know so that empathy has
helped me out a lot and I'm still
struggling with it till this day yes
because it's just now she has to
understand that's not how I grew up so
help me yeah I mean you guys are very
vocal as a family you guys are you you
guys talk you guys deny each other you
debate so it's it's a different reality
yeah lately because what makes our
reality is the first six years that we
spend in our household that's that's a
we're just a open program first six
years of life we're just learning
everything of how a family's supposed to
be how the world is supposed to be how
people are supposed to treat each other
yeah none of this stuff is like weird
making a decision we're just absorbing
yeah so if someone violates that program
we go you're wrong it's like a virus the
virus has entered yeah you want attack
it this is this is the real world you're
[ __ ] it up you're crazy
so that's that's what ends up happening
so then moving on to the D part that's
basically direction or discipline so
once you've got the belief end and then
you could believe that you could do
better now you have the awareness like
Mariel is aware that she's taking no
personally yeah as a cell is a personal
attack right now she has a direction to
change that Oh every time David says no
he's not insulting me yeah he's saying
no just to the thing I'm talking about
yeah and we can't have disputes we can
disagree he doesn't have to say yes to
everything
I do yeah right but then you have to
have the discipline to follow that so
the same I guess the method to anything
that you want to change your program I
just keep it simple like that and I got
to remember that human beings are in
different stages yeah so a lot of people
are stuck because there's this whole
it's like a virus thoughts are viruses
sometimes so they spread right and then
that be
comes the reality yeah so the reality
right now is everyone's anxious
everyone's depressed
everyone's this everyone's that right
everyone's in this shady pers like world
but in reality it's like dude we're
living way better than our grandparents
yeah it seems like everyone's trying to
one-up each other yeah like oh you're
depressed no like I'm so depressed like
do you know what I call it I call it the
oppression Olympics dude everybody's in
the oppression Olympiad no big Oh Oh
like we I talked about this and in this
this is like a cyclical topic but it's
like for example with like prejudice
right there oh well this is what my
people went through goes oh your people
went to that well guess what my people
went through this like dude what did you
go through anything personally no victim
right now like that right Jesse Jesse
yeah yeah like why that like why is that
even a thing like why are you even
expending energy on pretending to get
beat up to make a statement it's cool
it's okay it's the quitting to do you
know like you're looking for drama or
like or people are just so fed up it's
cool to take to get all the sympathy
points and I think it's understandable
for me when a teenager does it right now
because I think we all went through that
Vince but now for how I see it is that
face is lasting a little too long it's
going in from teenager to your early
twenties now into these thirty year olds
right it goes you should have fixed that
during your figure out face from like I
say like from thirteen all the way to
about like 20 to 23 minutes or just
slowly figure it out you know piece by
piece yeah but now because it's the norm
before you know people want pity all the
time it's like you trying to say I'm
running away from home every day yeah
it's like that's what it is all the time
it's like [ __ ] just do it then who
gives a [ __ ] yes point eventually you're
gonna have to face your [ __ ] demon
yeah you know you can't keep running
away from it all the time and you just
keep pointing fingers at everybody else
there's gonna be the same place it sucks
it's a terrible place to be when I when
I go to these college shows to people it
is very apparent that a lot of the times
some of these kids not all very I say a
decent amount just don't like
responsibility they don't want it they
don't wanna get their hands dirty yes
and they you know not just cause you
know I say adults now too I see people
in our millennial age yeah they they
hate they want everything but they don't
want all
[ __ ] that comes along with it yeah and
that's so unrealistic yeah but it's also
human nature yeah cuz it's like so it's
like government right like for cents a
Donna time you want the government to
take care of everything for you but you
don't want to be involved in the
government but we're a democracy we're
all supposed to be involved yeah but we
just want things to run smoothly you
know like we want everything to be
smooth without us putting in work you
know and I think that's I think that's
normal but it's unrealistic and it's
gonna bite a lot of people in the ass in
the future but I mean I feel like our
parents have been saying this to us like
you're not responsible their parents
were probably saying that [ __ ] to them
and like yeah we remember that hot topic
that came out it was I forgot what
[ __ ] news source said this but it was
like Millennials don't know how to do
basic [ __ ] learning how to sew but or
whatever right yeah and then they say
some stuff and and basically the the
backlash behind that was that
well it's your parents fault because
they they're the ones they we inherit a
[ __ ] up world
yeah and it was like okay but my motto
argument to that is I could be on your
side and I do understand cuz I'm a
millennial too but every kid or parent
has had that same cyclical argument yeah
it's like well my parents should have
done this it's nobody's reinventing the
wheel here yeah right so you we're gonna
blame our parents and then our parents
blame their parents so it's not
something new yeah you know and so
they're they're treating it as if oh
well your parents taught you know their
parents didn't teach them [ __ ] either my
parents had to figure it out as long as
they were going my dad was a my grandpa
[ __ ] wasted all of his money yeah we
apparently my dad was pretty well-off my
grandpa invested his money into the
wrong people took all the money out my
dad lived in [ __ ] poverty yeah so
it's not like his dad did well either so
we're all just kind of learning as we're
going you know I just don't like that
thing where people are still looking to
blame somebody else for something
nowadays we don't really have an excuse
yeah like we kind of don't because the
information out exactly what that alone
is if you want a certain piece of
information it's out there
but people want it to be delivered in a
certain way which I understand but they
want it to be simplified they want it to
be clean concise they want it to be
presented to them immediately where it's
died
yeah but that's just not the case and
you have to get your hands dirty and
kind of do some of that work yourself I
mean it's it's crazy just just to think
about our childhood like we had to get
information yet to go physically to a
library that was the only yes if you
it's either that or an adult tells you
something that's the only information
that you got you have any oh how hard
was get porn that she was so fat she was
so [ __ ] hard you lucky [ __ ] yeah
porn at the tip of your [ __ ] hands
now you can do everything it could be a
millionaire just on your phone you can
learn how to build a business on Google
yeah you could [ __ ] open up a YouTube
page you could do whatever you could
record your videos on your phone you
could post like everything